the british foreign secretary has warned
russia of severe consequences if it
attacks ukraine
liz truss made the remarks before
welcoming g7 counterparts to a
weekend-long meeting in the english port
city of liverpool trust hopes the group
of the world's richest democracies can
show a united front against russia as
the country appears to be massing troops
along ukraine's border russia denies it
plans to attack
here's more of what trusts had to say
if russia were to take that action it
would be
a strategic mistake
and there would be severe consequences
for russia and what we're doing this
weekend is working with like-minded
allies to spell that out
so for more on this i'm joined by dw's
chief international editor richard
walker richard welcome the british
foreign secretary essentially firing a
verbal warning shot at russia there what
exactly is the situation like at the
russia-ukraine border and just how
worried should we be yeah well obviously
we've been reporting about this over the
last couple of months um
the build-up of perhaps north of 100 000
troops or so according to
a western intelligence estimates uh in
the border regions uh in russia but but
close to the the ukrainian border and
without really a plausible explanation
from the russian side of what these
troops are doing and this is coupled
with threatening rhetoric coming from
the russian side the kind of rhetoric
that appears like it might be designed
to justify a possible military
intervention if it does come to that and
then of course there's the fact that
this has happened before we're not
talking about something that would be
completely unheard of um vladimir putin
has had a track record not to see
ukraine but also for example with the
with a view to georgia and other former
soviet republic so this very much has
the west's attention as we see at this
g7 foreign minister ministers meeting
here where they're trying to establish
kind of credible deterrence towards
russia and also during the course of the
week uh joe biden us president held a
video call with vladimir putin his
russian counterpart also to try and
spell out uh the western position now
short of actual armed conflict what
diplomatic tools does the west have in
its arsenal to counter russia yeah so we
do have to stress that at the beginning
ukraine's not say a nato member state
where the where the west would be uh uh
bound by uh treaty obligations to
intervene militarily but in that call
for example between joe biden and
vladimir putin biden essentially used
three sticks and one carrot
so the sticks were as uh his national
security advisor spoke afterwards first
of all to respond with very strong
economic sanctions now there are
long-standing sanctions against russia
anyway from from past actions against
crime uh for instance uh the annexation
of crimean but part of ukraine um but
there are escalations that the west
could apply for instance really going
for uh sanctions within the financial
system or something that would be a kind
of a sanctions nuclear option which
would be uh blocking russian access to
the swift payment system this is the
kind of thing that's been used for
example about against north korea in the
past that would have very very huge uh
implications for the russian economy
then the other sticks were providing
additional defense material to the
ukrainian so not actually sending in
troops but providing them with more
weapons potentially and then fortifying
uh the nato countries in the region
and one carrot offering to the russians
to have talks about their kind of bigger
overall concerns strategically in the
region the sense that russia often talks
about about feeling that the west nato
for example is constantly trying to
encroach towards their borders so biden
offered the carrot of talks on that okay
now this is of course the first g7
meeting for germany's new foreign
minister and elena berbach of the
environmentalist green party and she and
germany are going to be facing a lot of
pressure from other g7 leaders to
abandon the nord stream ii gas pipeline
over fears that that's going to increase
reliance on russian gas is there a
scenario under which you see this
actually happening yeah well it's
interesting isn't it so nordstrom 2 if
it was up to analina berbock and her
green party
that pipeline wouldn't be going ahead
anyway they've opposed it for a long
time but this is a coalition government
that's come in here in germany and the
social democrats were in charge the
chancellor's olaf schultz they've
broadly been more supportive but still a
russian invasion of ukraine would make
it really kind of stretch that
commitment to nordstrom 2 to breaking
limit and also earlier in the year the
us and germany
agreed a deal between the two sides that
meant that the us agreed to not apply
sanctions to german firms in incl
involved in nordstrom 2 under which the
germans
committed to this if russia attempted to
use energy as a weapon or committed
further aggressive acts against ukraine
germany will take action to limit
russian export capabilities to europe in
the energy sector including gas doesn't
name ns2 specifically nordstrom 2
but you know that's as close as you
could get to actually a commitment to
take some action like this richard
walker dw's chief international editor
thanks so much for joining me with that
update in the studio
and meanwhile germany's new chancellor
olaf schwarz has had his first call with
us president joe biden since taking
office they discussed those tensions on
the russia-ukraine border earlier
schultz was in brussels for talks with
european union and nato leaders where
again russia's troop build-up was high
on the agenda schultz said he wants to
revive negotiations with russia to
de-escalate tensions and avoid a
military conflict
olaf schultz began his day in paris with
a business lunch with french president
emmanuel macron
a quick bonjour in front of the elysee
palace then off to discuss franco-german
relations and challenges facing the eu
the new german chancellor said he was
optimistic about future cooperation
between europe's two biggest economies
from my point of view
there are now also good starting points
for what needs to be done next
they include germany's g7 presidency as
well as france's eu council presidency
the challenge is to ensure that we can
make great progress in all these areas
i'm sure that we will succeed
and this was a first visit on which we
can strengthen our cooperation and ties
a pressing issue on the agenda growing
tensions at the russian ukrainian border
the two leaders showed a united front
our ultimate goal is to prevent all
unnecessary tension
the common will of europeans and
americans is to show that we are very
vigilant and that there is no further
escalation
next stop for schultz the heart of the
eu itself
in brussels he met european commission
president ozula van der leyen and used
the chance to stress the role of germany
in the eu
germany is a european nation
we are a large country at the heart of
the european union
we have a large population a large
economy
and that is why german politics cannot
stand at the side and simply comment on
what's going on
relations with russia eu cooperation on
the pandemic response and the joint
effort to tackle climate change were
some of the topics discussed at the
commission's headquarters
later schultz also met with european
council president sean michel
michelle sets the agenda of the council
of eu leaders which is due to convene
next week
it will be the first such gathering for
schultz as german chancellor
he ended his marathon day with a last
meeting with nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg
again russia's troop build up on the
ukrainian border took center stage
schultz made clear a russian incursion
into ukrainian territory would be
unacceptable
dw's brussels bureau chief alexander von
naman has been following the chancellor
during his first trip to brussels and
she sent us this assessment
chancellor olaf schultz used his
inaugural trip to paris and brussels to
emphasize that his government stands for
continuity concerning germany's foreign
policy he also made clear that he is
eager to work closely together with
partners and eu institutions to
strengthen the european union and its
role on the international stage and that
message went down well in paris and in
brussels schultz is well known in
european capitals as merkel's former
vice chancellor and finance minister and
he knows exactly how the european union
works which gives him a flying start
here in brussels
however the honeymoon will soon be over
and schultz will be facing a number of
international challenges including
tensions with russia and fears that
moscow could be planning another
incursion into ukraine
the german chancellor warned russia that
massing troops on ukraine's border was
unacceptable and that any aggression
would have serious consequences
however he dodged questions whether in
that case germany would be willing to
hold the controversial north stream to
gas pipeline
there might be some tough choices ahead
for the new german chancellor
you